hello my name is Carlo Giacometti I will
talk about neural networks for audio and
as the title says I will show some
example easy example applications of
neural network applied to audio
classification problems so the main
topics I will talk about is first of all
feature extraction and values
declinations of that and then I will
have some as more example applications
and these are all things that I was able
to train very quickly in my machine so
it's kind of some toy examples regarding
neural networks and audio so as we said
feature extraction this is very
important so this is one audio object in
Mathematica it's
is this enough
okay
so this is just a simple recording right
then perfect timing
but what is underneath this it's a bunch
of numbers this in this case we have a
list of samples that's about 100,000
samples one problem is that the length
is variable here I am just grabbing the
whole collection of example data that we
have as you can see there is a huge
variety of lengths in this case it is
quite a big amount of data so the first
step that we can take to bring this kind
of data in a more reasonable format is
partition the signal as you can see this
kind of looks like an image but looked
like the problem is that this first
dimension is still valuable it depends
on how much you record and the
partitions are very sensitive to the
beginning point that you choose so they
are very sensitive to face variation the
first step we can take is apply a
Fourier transform on each partition to
minimize the sensitivity of the face so
this is what I'm doing here I'm mapping
the fovea transfer and taking in this
case the absolute value and usually the
phase information is not crucial for
many classification tasks so we just
described that and this is something
that many of you might have seen already
this is a spectrogram on this axis we
see the time and on this axis we see the
frequency this is much more stable to
face variation so if I move the endpoint
of my partitions what I see in the
Fourier transform is fairly stable we
have introduced the dimension of the
input damage though so what we can do is
remap this spectrogram onto a nonlinear
scale in this case I am using the null
scale which kind of mimics human
perception or frequency
we perceived mostly logarithmically the
operation involves filtering the specter
gun with a bunch of filters whose Center
frequencies are spaced according to the
small scale in this case I am choosing
60 filters I am applying this operation
to it as you can see we went very much
down in dimensionality of the problem
this is the reasonable invariant phase
shift phase shifts and kind of mimics
human perception and as you can see this
is looks fairly similar to what we saw
in the previous slide the further step
is to reduce dimensionality even more is
a common strategy is to apply a discrete
cosine transform to the mouse bacterium
and discard all the higher variable
components that's according to the
assumption that most of the information
lives in the lower-level components of
the mal frequency septal coefficients
and here we go this is much less
intuitive what this axis represents is
not immediately obvious but it retains
most of the information especially for
signals like speech recordings as you
can see we went from a hundred thousand
elements to a matrix of four hundred by
13 elements so this is a good result in
dimensionality reduction we still have
the problem of variable length though we
didn't tackle that long so why do we
care about this
we do have neural networks that can deal
with signals of variable length like
some example layers from those are the
basic recomment layer the long short
term memory layer etcetera etc but we
know that convolutional nets can be very
effective and extremely lightweight in
terms of training times
computation effort so we would like to
leverage all the knowledge that we have
from image processing and neural
networks so what we can do is partition
again our signal into fixed sized
windows and say one second windows and
then map a convolutional network onto
each partition so this is what we could
have for example from the original
signal you see I have a list of images
in the end that have all the same
dimensions the only valuable thing is
the length of this list but we don't
have too much about that because we are
simply mapping the same network on all
elements of this list so this is
captions I think most of the aspects of
feature extraction that are relevant for
audio neural networks so some examples
the first example I want to show is
digit recognition I'm I'm sure you are
all familiar with the feminist examples
of images we have a data set of images
each is a handwritten digit from 0 to 9
here we have essentially the same thing
only we have recordings Wow evidently we
are not happy playing this
well playbook is not working very well
but a per each class and as you can see
we have digits from 0 to 9 we have a
corresponding record I mean a disclaimer
is that this data set is an open source
data set so the amount of data is more
there are only three speakers so we
cannot expect whatever result we get to
generalize well so first of all what
kind of feature extraction are we f
extraction are we planning to apply on
to this data we are planning to do an
FCC extraction we have a fixed duration
of one second and we use just we will
use only the F 21st coefficients
resulting of death from this computation
one thing that is crucial and is that we
will need to do some de documentation
given the very tiny size of this data
set
so for each recording whenever we feed
it to the neural network for training we
will randomly shift the signal by a time
shift that will have a maximum of point
25 seconds it's an important note
everything I will show today will use
this all utilities get feature batch
function this is something we have been
developing and it was ready just before
the conference but in 11 3 and we will
bundle this functionality unto a net
encoder of audio and that will take care
of all this without the user having to
worry about how to generate example so
all of this kind of sketchy phase of
feature extraction will be taken care of
matically in net encoder so let's look
at what kind of features we are
computing here I'm getting for examples
as you can see the dimensions per each
example have a very tiny 20 by 31 matrix
and they look like this
so it's a fairly small problem the
network that we will be looking at is
very similar actually to the Linette
network so it's just a couple of
convolutional layers with pooling at the
end and then a couple of linear layers
for classification that's look at this
the training will be so as I said I am
using this internal function currently
this will get substituted by a net
encoder of audio directly in the network
definition as you can see the training
can go quite fast despite we are talking
about audio files that live on the hard
drive and we are doing the feature
extraction online so the features are
not precomputed I will actually stop the
training and imported pre-trained
Network I think the total training time
was not more than 10 minutes though so
it is definitely something you can play
on your machines with and we can look at
the results on the dining data of course
we get very good results but we get
similar results in terms of accuracy
also on the test data we get about 90%
of accuracy and which is a fairly good
result one way to test that is I could
record a digit spoken on my with my
voice and see if the net does something
sensible as I said the network has been
trained only on three speakers so I
wouldn't expect it to generalize too
well but it's still worth trying five
let's see if it worked yep it actually
gives a good result
shadi tried this yesterday it didn't
work because there is no female voice in
the training data so data is the most
important thing in this situations the
second example is about classifying cats
and dogs because of course who doesn't
want to look or listener cats and dogs
and so I can a dog as you can imagine
the class sorry the variables here are
named cat classes cut everything I
prefer cats so the classes are easy is
just cat or dog it's a binary
classification task here we are looking
at the male spectrum rather than M FCC
we want to capture a bit more
information than just 20 M FCC
coefficients here we are using 60
filters to compute the mouse bacterium
as you can see and a fixed duration of
0.9 seconds and these are some examples
of the features that will be computed on
our later this is a slightly more big
network it's just the convolution layers
have a smaller filter size and there are
more of them the end result is kind of
similar and at the end we still have the
usual linear layers for classification
purposes the training is a bit slower
here I will not demonstrate but this
also took no more than half an hour to
try and get reasonable results of my
machine I will import the prepend
Network and let's look at the classifier
measurements good accuracy on training
data not as good accuracy on test data
but still not insanely bad so I want to
do here is I take out
last layer of network so I will get a
vector of length two there each input
example and what I want to do is a
visualization of this like two vector to
see if we actually can separate in a two
dimensional space cats and dogs let's
see I am grabbing a random sample of 30
example from the training data the color
is the proper label and we can see two
different clusters of I would say cat
and and as you can see we can achieve a
very nice separation in the featured
space so the next example is instrument
recognition here the data set is a
bigger one and more reliably constructed
one than the other two that I showed and
in this case we have excerpts from songs
and the labels is the predominant
instrument in that clip in that
two-second clip we have various classes
sort of the abbreviation it's something
like salut clarinet flute acoustic
guitar electric guitar etc etcetera here
we want to keep even more information
with respect to what we did before
so we are computing a mel spectrogram
but with 128 filters we want to keep a
very good frequency resolution and to
gather information about the instruments
and also here we are working on a fixed
duration of one second and there is
still a documentation part that randomly
shifts the signal
so hopefully it will generalize it will
help to generalize well the dimensions
slightly bigger 31 by 128 as I said 128
is the size the number of filters that
we are using in the mass spectrum and
these are what some of them look like
math well let's see if we can get it
slightly nicer example okay so this one
for example house there we can see a
clear harmonic structure into this one
and this is what our neural network will
be exposed to the network here is
essentially equivalent to death cats and
dog classifier so a bunch of
convolutional layers with a small filter
size and we increase as the width as the
depth of the network increases we
symmetrically increase the width of the
network and at the end we usually we
have the usual pooling and leaner layers
to to do some classification again I
will skip the training part and import
the treatment net and here I pre
computed the measurements actually on
because the amount of data is fairly
sizable and the network takes a little
bit to evaluate so we get 80% 85%
accuracy on the training data and a
similar result on the test data so it
seems to generalize quite well it didn't
learn example by example we are still
ignoring the time dependence of the
problem we are the rich sample we are
extracting one single one side one
second segment so what can we do to take
this time dependence into account so
first of all we can complete we can
generate the full ml spectrogram of the
signal so this will have a variable like
and then we partition this into
one-second partitions so what we have is
now a sequence of one-second long
partitions and then as I mentioned in
the Futurist action path we can actually
map the network that we have already
trained onto each partition so this is
one example of the feature we will be
looking at so there is a list of fixed
size images that corresponds to one
single label so this is voice sample and
this is the time evolution of this voice
sample saying here for a flute I get a
list of that shows the evolution as a
function of time of the of the signal so
we can take the network that we train
before and chop off the neck decoder
that was doing their classification so
what what we end up having is a network
that takes a fixed size to the
two-dimensional vector well three
dimensional if we take channels into
consideration and outputs a vector of
length 11 and what we can do is map this
network onto this list of images to do
mattresses so if we only apply it onto
one of these features we get as I said a
list of length 11 but what we want to do
is actually map onto a sequence of
two-dimensional mattresses so what I did
here is visualize this I am doing this
operation on many examples each row is
in each row there are 10 examples that
correct
onto a single label the horizontal axis
will tell you which class we are the
network is classifying to and the
vertical axis is time so if we see a
single straight line let me see if I can
increase the size of this
so it will be slightly more clear okay
if we see a single vertical line and
this network is fairly sure from the
beginning to the end of the signal it
belongs to this class but we have
several a situation where sure it starts
in one class but then the situation is
kind of not obvious and then it gets
miss classified as a different one so
how can we improve onto this situation
we could given des is simply a sequence
of length eleven vectors we could apply
a recurrent network onto this input here
so this is what I have here I map our
chopped net onto the input and then I
have a bunch of long short term memory
layers a sequence last layer to get only
one label from this sequence and then
some linear layer for classification
also here I will import a Britain that
this actually took quite a bit of time
to Train and as you can see we improved
the results quite dramatically this
could be time or the training didn't
flatten out on my machine I just
essentially ran out of time so I can see
this getting better results so by taking
into account the time dependence of the
signal we managed to squeeze some more
accuracy out of the pre-trained net that
was acting on fixed size partitions of
the signal and my last example is
acoustics in classification this is a
very complicated problem the idea is
that you have you put a microphone into
an environment say a street or a
restaurant or a park or something like
that record whatever is coming to it and
then you need to classify what
environment you are looking at so there
are two I will show two example here
going off it allowed
they're not very loud this is supposed
to be a tongue cytokine so these are
family book examples but I guess they
give the idea and we have a bunch of
classes that are present in this data
set
also here we are doing a fixed size
partition of 1.4 seconds and we are
still computing and mouse bacterium this
time with less precision we are only
considering 40 filters hopefully that
will be enough to capture information
about the acoustic scene and the big
problem the main reason why this is
difficult to do with traditional signal
processing techniques is that you can
have a huge variety of sounds that
happen in a specific scene that
translates to a huge variety of actually
shapes that you can see in a spectrogram
so this is an extremely complicated
classification in terms of classical
signal processing
I will still use a very simple Network
this is again go if you go back to the
first example of the digit
classification this is the same one so a
couple of convolutional layers and then
some linear ones for classification and
again I will cheat and import the
pre-trained Network this one actually
took quite a bit of time to get some
results and accuracy of this of this
network on training tests and on a
training set is very high 19 6% is
extremely high result but if you look at
the test set as you can see this network
didn't generalize very well there are a
lot of misconceptions a lot of
misclassified examples here they are not
unreasonable I mean one of the biggest
myths classification is this one and
it's a cafe or restaurant misclassified
as go sister so you could have you those
are fairly similar environments or a
library misclassified as an office so
these are fairly understandable mistakes
so what are the solutions for this well
I guess just a more varied data set and
possibly a bigger dropout to increase
the generalization of network can reduce
the accuracy on the training set and
another operation that can be done is
what we did in the previous example to
take into account the evolution of a sip
or the time evolution of an accoustic
scene and so adding a bunch of recurrent
layers on top of this convolution that
acts on fixed size partitions
okay this was the last example this is
the team that has been working on audio
hours and of course most of this is
possible thanks to their neural networks
framework so they are not in this line
there are too many people but this is
these are is the team that has been
working on audio processing thank you
[Applause]